Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to see how OpenAI’s DALL-E
2 AI’s images stack up to real works from
real artists.
This is going to be an amazing journey, so,
hold on tight to your papers!
DALL-E 2 is an AI that took the world by storm
in the last few months.
What does it do?
Well, we can write it a text description,
and hand it to the AI that creates an amazing
image of exactly that.
And now, I am lucky to say that, yes, I have
ascended!
Thanks to the generosity of OpenAI, I now
have access to DALL-E 2.
And my first thought was, that if it can come
up with high-quality, and truly novel images,
let’s put those to the real test.
In other words, see how they stand up against
the works of real artists.
Our first subject will be my favorite artist
in the world, and that would be my wife, Felícia
Zsolnai-Fehér.
She drew this chimpanzee.
Oh my, that is beautiful.
So, let’s try this against DALL-E 2.
Okay, but how?
Well, the first way of trying it will be through
variant generation.
What is that?
Well, since this AI is trained to understand
the connection between text and images, the
understanding goes both ways.
This means that we can not only input text
and get an image, but input an image too.
Does it understand what is depicted in this
image?
Let’s see.
Oh yes.
Wow, it not only understands what is going
on, but it can demonstrate that by creating
really good variants of it.
But, not nearly as good as Felícia, I have
to say.
Let’s give it another chance.
Here, I used a text prompt to get a hand-drawn
chimp looking to the right.
And I asked for lots and lots of detail.
I’ve pleaded and pleaded for extra wrinkles
to squeeze everything out of the AI, even
cherrypicked the results, and these were the
best I could get.
You know, art is highly subjective, that’s
what makes it what it is.
But for now, I have to say Team Humanity,
team AI, 1-0.
At this point, I thought this is going to
be easy.
Easy easy easy.
And boy, you’ll find out in a moment how
wrong I was.
Here is a work from one of my other favorite
artists, Judit Somogyvári.
Wow.
That is one of her original characters, very
imaginative, I love it.
So, let’s ask for a variant of that.
Does the AI understand what is going on?
You know, there is a lot to take in here,
elf ears, make up, and the…wow.
I cannot believe that.
I am lucky that the variants are working out
so well, because writing a prompt for this
would be a bit of a challenge.
I am truly out of words.
These are so good.
But, not as good as Judit, in my opinion.
Team Humanity vs Team AI, 2-0.
That’s a good score, but it is getting harder.
Now, let’s look at one of Judit’s other
works.
An ostrich that is also a formula one racer.
I am loving this, especially the helmet and
the goggles.
I think I can whip up a good prompt for this.
So, what did the AI come up with?
Holy mother of papers!
Is this some kind of joke?
It cannot be that good.
I checked the images over and over again.
It is that good.
Wow.
Now, of course, scoring this is subjective,
but clearly, both are excellent.
I’ll give this one a tie.
Team Humanity vs Team AI, 3-1.
I told you, it is getting harder.
Make sure to check out both Judit, and Felícia’s
works, the links are available in the video
description.
And now, for the next test, please give a
warm welcome to the King of All Donuts.
Of course, that is the great Andrew Price,
3d modeler and teacher extraordinaire.
Now, here are some of the donuts I came up
with using DALL-E 2.
And some from the prompts that I ran for my
daughter.
Loving the googly eyes there, by the way.
So, these are some great donuts.
Now, Andrew, it’s your turn.
Let’s see…wow OpenAI’s was a good one,
but this, this is a Michelin-star donut right
there.
The AI-made ones are no match for Andrew’s
skills.
So, Team Humanity vs Team AI, 4-1.
Note that DALL-E 2 often isn’t as good as
a real, world-class artist, but the AI can
create 10000 of these images a day.
That must be worth at least a point.
So, 4-2.
Whew!
We made it.
Now, all this testing is great fun, and of
course, highly subjective, so don’t take
it too seriously.
And here comes the even more important lesson.
In my opinion, this tool should not be framed
at all as Team Humanity versus Team AI.
I believe this should be framed as Team Humanity,
supercharged by Team AI.
Here’s why through 6 inspiring examples.
Look.
First, this is my second favorite prompt ever,
a grumpy cat in a spaceship.
That is incredible.
Now, almost as soon as I posted it on Twitter,
it inspired Fabian to create an animated version
of it.
And now, our adorable little Grump is ready
for takeoff.
Through the ingenuity of Team Human and Team
AI together.
So cool!
What a time to be alive!
So, I hear you asking, if this was my second
favorite, what is the first?
Well, two, have a look at this fox scientist.
I cannot believe how well this came out.
It has tons of personality.
And, it also inspired others to repaint it.
Here it is.
You see, I don’t see this as a competition.
I see this as collaboration.
Three, it also inspired the great beardyman,
who wanted to see a platypus studying the
schematics for a cold fusion reactor.
These are absolutely amazing, not just the
quality, but the variety of the results.
My goodness.
Note that he asked for a one-eyed platypus,
but this iteration of DALL-E is not that good
with numbers.
Yet.
If it could talk, it would probably apologize
for it.
Four, I also ran a prompt for David Brown
from Boyinaband which got real interesting
real quick.
He was looking for a visual pun.
What is that?
Is this a pan?
Is this the pun, that we got a pan instead?
I am not sure, but this is very cool nonetheless.
And I also wonder what the AI is trying to
say here.
Five, James from Linus Tech Tips also ran
a superb prompt.
A time traveler insensitive to humanity's
trivialities.
What a great idea!
Oh my, loving the framing and the thoughtfulness
of these results.
And finally, six, it inspired me too.
I also made this.
All hail the mighty Cyberfrog!
Loving it.
And we also have a tiny chihuahua in our home
and in the Two Minute Papers labs.
She is Rosie, the paper dog, if you will.
This is how we see her.
And now, we can also show how she sees herself
when meeting other dogs.
Oh yes, I think that is very accurate.
And of course, as always, +1.
You did not think we would leave without looking
at some of you Fellow Scholars holding on
to your papers, did you?
Here you go.
And as you see, these are some proper papers.
You Fellow Scholars are loving it.
But now, let’s have an even more explosive
paper, like DALL-E 2.
Oh yes!
Now we are talking!
This scholar is you, who knows that this paper
is history in the making.
So much so that I cannot stop thinking about
and playing with this thing.
It really keeps me up at night.
This is an incredible achievement that is
going to transform the world around us.
And fast.
So, artists, AI people, what do you think?
Which results did you like better?
Let me know in the comments below!
Also, I will be on Twitter taking some requests
from my followers, so make sure to follow
us there and send some prompts!
The best ones may appear in a future episode
here.
The link
is in the description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!